[موسيقى]
اعتقد بان المجتمع له اثر محدود واما كانت
محدوده ولكن يجب على مجتمع الدولي السعي
وراءه اي فرصه
وكل الاجواء غير مشجعه وكذلك عدم
الاستسلامه في خضم كل ما يجري
المصدر الوحيد للمساعدات الاجنبيه
المجتمع الدولي لمكافحه المجاعه وهذا امر
مهم جدا
ومن المخيب
للاعمال ان تكون كلها المساعدات الانسانيه
محدوده جدا
وقرار الطالبان فيما يخص المراه ايضا مخيب
جدا
لانهم وعدوا باشياء مختلفه وكان يبدو انهم
سيسمحون للفتيات بالذهاب الى المدارس
وحتى بعد المدارس
الابتدائيه والثانويه ولكن القياده
الدينيه اتخذت قرارا مختلفا
[موسيقى]
هذا صحيح
او هذا الامر غير طبيعي على الاطلاق
اداره شامبو وقرارها لتفاوض مع طالبا من
دون مشاركه الحكومه الافغانيه
كانت
مفاجئه جدا وغير متوقعه
والقرار ايضا كان غير متوازن والاتفاق
الذي تم التوصل اليه عهده كان بمثابه
وثيقه استسلام والرئيس بايدن بخلاف مشورته
كافه قاده الجيش والاجهزه الاستخباراتيه
وحتى المستشاري الدبلوماسيين قرر تطبيق
هذا القرار او الاتفاق
لا نستطيع ان ندافع عن هذا القرار واي
رئيس اخر ربما ما كان سيفعل ذلك